if you've never been to an irish wake
and i've only seen the movie version you
probably think it's just another irish
piss up with few people round a coffin
drinking pints of guinness but you would
be very wrong
in my father's island off the coast of
mail people go to the wakes of their
neighbors they see dead bodies they
touch dead bodies they take children to
those wakes so even an ordinary life
away from the medical profession
would have seen 20 30 50 sometimes 100
dead bodies
my father didn't want to die he was only
70. he was a very powerfully physically
fit man
but then he got pancreatic cancer
and pancreatic cancer is one of those
cancers that no one ever recovers from
he was quite stoic about it
and more importantly his community
accepted his fate
they came to see him in the dying
process
the house filled with visitors
so many visitors that you actually
thought the house was celebrating a
wedding feast
i was at the foot of my father's death
bed
and i looked around
and there were 12 people in the room
some of whom
i didn't know
and at that moment
the imraw kinsha the chief keener struck
up a very familiar catholic prayer
called the five sorrowful mysteries
holy mary mother god pray for us now
about the hour of our death and then the
chorus return that other chant holy mary
mother of god pray for sinners now and
at the hour of our death
and when the chorus said that second
verse that sound grew louder
and louder
and louder in that room
until it was almost
the loudest sound i've ever heard in my
life i saw in that moment
that what these people were doing were
cradling this man
into death
like a lullaby
and that this death was not a western
hospital but a right within an irish
clan a way of dealing with death that
was probably as old as the fall of joy
a mechanism by which people could share
their death
share this experience
learn about their own deaths
and also
share this normalize this within their
community
later the same day my father dead father
was taken he was placed in a coffin and
just moved a few feet away into the
front sitting room and there we had a
full old-fashioned irish wake
where the women came
again they're called the imbrog kinsha
keening women and they
sort of controlled the stage of the wake
their the emotional temperature whether
they cried and keened
when a new mourner came in there was a
kind of wave of emotion
which used to ripple through the room
it was a process for which you drained
out emotion where you moved on to the
stages of acceptance of the death
and then then we um waked with my father
the whole
night through
during this week as well there were lots
of children
around there were
three-year-olds and five-year-olds
playing at the feet of the coffin the
house is full of people
talking feasting
being served tea in sandwiches
the other thing about the irish wake is
people come in great numbers to the
funerals
so my father although he's a very
ordinary man
had three or four hundred people who
came to his funeral
who were also under a moral obligation
to shake the hands
of the principal bereaved
so it wasn't just enough for them to be
there in the crowd
they all came up to you and shook your
hands
and uh as they shook your hands they
sort of like a cliche they say sorry for
your trouble
in fact they shake your hands so many
times that your hand the bones in your
hand begin to ache this is a way of
countering death denial
because these individuals are shaking
your hand pressing into your flesh and
they're saying
it's not just sorry for your trouble but
they're dead they're dead they're dead
they're dead they're dead so you at the
end of that
that existential experience it's very
hard to then think
they're coming back
which again is a very normal grief
reaction
think the best way
to deal with death is not to invent a
new ritual or appoint another priest
cast of bereavement counsellors or
medical professionals
it is to do what we've always done
and that's gather together as fellow
mortals
in the face of our mortality
and seek
to bridge that moment of bereavement and
loss together
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video